[Musique]
c'est le salon de l'étudiant de
Versailles qui va nous intéressé à
présent fanine Mourino bonsoir vous êtes
la nouvelle vice-présidente du CVU le
Conseil des études et de la vie
universitaire de l'Université de
Versailles SaintQuentin en iveline
pourquoi un salon de l'étudiant à
Versailles c'est la 2e édition oui c'est
la 2e édition donc l'université a
organisé l'année dernière avec
l'étudiant un salon qui est finalement
une déclinaison du salon national mais
une déclinaison locale
nous avons reçu 14000 visiteurs l'année
dernière il nous paraissait important de
de remettre de refaire cette cet
événement il faut savoir que
l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yveline est la seule université du
78 que nous avons un ancrage territorial
très fort puisque nous avons des
formations sur Versailles mais sur
Saint-Quentin sur manthe sur véisie et
sur ambouillet donc vous constatez que
nous avons un réel ancrage territorial
donc donc là c'est un plus véritablement
pour les étudiants de se rendre sur ce
type de salon plus proche de chez eux
bien sûr bien sûr vous savez que
l'orientation est une question très
difficile pour le lycéen sur une
orientation post bac pour des raisons
financières pratiques mais aussi
affective on sait souvent que le lycéen
souhaite avoir une formation proche de
chez lui et donc il est excessivement
important que nous puissions informer
des différentes formations sur le
territoire du 78 destiné au lycéen de ce
département alors l'université sera bien
évidemment représentée sur ce salon de
l'étudiant puisque vous faites partie
des organisateurs très précisément au
rez-de-chaussée du Palais des Congrès
puisque c'est au Palais des Congrès que
ce rendez-vous se déroule il y aura
également les lycées publics des
Yvelines les lycées de l'enseignement
catholique la ville de Versailles avec
l'école des beauards aussi représenté
puis toutes les les écoles quasiment du
département qui seront présentes quel
type d'information les étudiants vont
pouvoir trouver parce que l'objectif
aussi pour l'université c'est ensuite de
les faire venir sur les portes ouvertes
exactement alors les lycéens vont
trouver au niveau de l'université 200
formations qui seront présenté et
représenté représenté par des
responsables de formation par des
enseignants par des étudiants qui sont
en étude aujourd'hui et donc les lycéens
avec leurs parents pourront découvrir
toutes les formations de proximité qui
sont proposé dans le 78 est-ce que vous
allez mettre en avant certaines des
formations estce qu'il y a des
formations qui qui marchent mieux en
tout cas qui on peut-être March moins
bien aussi qu'il faut mettre en avant
nous avons nous avons 200 formations
donc nous sommes une université
pluridisciplinaire donc il y a toutes
sortes de formations non elles sont
toutes de qualité pas de pas de raison
particulière d'en valoriser une plus que
l'autre alors en tout cas sur ce salon
comme sur tous les salons il y a aussi
des conférences qui sont organisées ques
sont les les les quelquesunes des
conférences qu'on pourra retrouver il y
en a 21 en tout al voilà il y a il y a
deux choses il y a des stands où là on
peut rencontrer les responsables des
formations et les étudiants comme je
vous disais et puis il y a aussi des
conférences qui sont animées où il y a
une présentation sur un thème et ensuite
une forme de débat avec des questions
qui peuvent être posées par les parents
et les lycéens voilà avec l'ensemble des
informations est-ce qu'il y a une
conférence ou deux qu'on peut mentionner
peut-être des rendez-vous à donnerx
étuud je les ai là si vous voulez ça
déroule sur de jours leoule sur des de
jours tout le programme est sur
l'étudiant et bien sûr sur le site il y
a énormément de conférences et le matin
et l'après-midi qui répondent je pense
globalement à toutes les questions qu'un
lycéen est en droit de se poser
aujourd'hui 14000 visiteurs l'an dernier
vous en attendez au moins autant cette
année on espère plus on imagine vous
l'avez dit 18 19 janvier salon de
l'étudiant à Versailles c'est la 2è
édition merci merci donc d'être venu
nous présenter ce rendez-vous le 78 de
ce soir qui se poursuit avec un
reportage à présent la solidarité qui
peut se décliner en jeu de société c'est
tout l'enjeu des rencontres solidaires
proposé ce samedi à la Maison de
l'Environnement am man lesamo Valérie
oribo tu sais ce qui se passe là tu
tombes malade et tu vas passer ton tour
hein
[Musique]
donc je suis pas malade toi tu vas jouer
deux fois de
suite deux tours d'affilé pour retenir
on peut apprendre à conduire à partir de
16 ans qu'on travaille à partir de 16
ans qu'on peut conduire tout seul à
partir de 18 ans découvrir les règles de
vie en société à travers des jeux
ludiques certes mais pas seulement la
Maison de l'Environnement de Manil et a
proposé de comparer les inégalités entre
citoyens du monde et de parler droit de
l'homme au plus jeune tout en s'amusant
je trve les de les sensibiliser à notre
monde et aussi de voir que il y a des
des pays qui n'ont pas les mêmes droit
que nous cette journée des rencontres
solidaires était organisé en partenariat
avec plusieurs associations humanitaires
de
l'agglomération j'ai déjà fait ça avec
un groupe de jeunes et ils on bien réagi
ils avaient bien
senti un petit peu dans leur presque
dans leur chair cette ces inégalités à
l'issue de ce jeu les enfants ont
adressé des courriers à ces inconnus du
bout du monde pour leur faire part de
leur soutien dans leur combat ce jour-là
la galette des rois aussi se voulait
solidaire